we got 45 minutes to pretty much to get
across the bridge we can't make it thin
and retro I think we can do it yeah
here at Pixar giving you a treat yeah
there's kind of wine forming here
Ben
an ice cream sandwich ice cream with you
back there you go joy to dippers please
condition
imagine somebody
she girls there
we just left Pixar Jeff on amazing I
never never thought this was never knew
this would happen oh no yeah kicks are
is very very cool I I can't say enough
about it they have Chuck each we
couldn't film yeah they have chuck e
cheese you know we used to have the
whole band they have the whole band and
they're gonna try and fix it up to get
it working but we saw saw saw anything
so many bigger so buddy
I got a new truck this year I'm going to
be taking up over here we go hi guys
were here at I mean oh there we go here
we go no secret
I know you see all the people ice cream
ice cream have you got that one soon and
I mean there's a lot of eyes going on
here just about a yearly actually down
palo alto before are you excited you
that's been appropriately excited oh I
don't want to scare anybody oh boy oh
boy
so what are we doing here
I think these people apparently and what
get some ice cream naturally
exactly
etiquette
always wouldn't weeks look at that I
don't know what they did I don't know
whatever I know neither do we but you
know what I'm gonna stand by those
people more likely then I'm gonna stand
by was a big company that probably screw
them old wooden